les études cliniques elles ont été
faites elles ont été bien faites et le
fait de faire des études
observationnelles c'est très bien
beaucoup d'erreurs en médecine ont été
basées sur le fait qu' on s'est basé sur
des études cliniques randomisées
rigoureuse mais toujours fait par
justement dans un contexte particulier
avec des patients qui étaient pas
volontairement sélectionné mais qui
représentait des france particulière et
c'est quand on passe en population
quand on passe dans la vraie vie et
quand vous voyez les résultats qui ont
été montrés par les autorités
israéliennes par ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis où je vis oui bien sûr
le vaccin diminue la mortalité et s'est
montrée avec des chiffres qui sont très
importants oui bien sûr on agit sur la
circulation du virus je pense que il ya
une démonstration qui n'a peut-être
jamais été fait en vaccination humaine
aux deux de l'efficacité d'un vaccin
c'est une approche qui n'est pas du tout
uniquement moi je devrai simplement dire
que je suis un porte parole
deux scientifiques c'est pour ça que
j'ai réagi en étant un peu choqué quand
on nous fait la leçon c'est que deux
gens qui réfléchissent de gens qui sont
indépendants des gens qui ont analysé
des études et il faut que alors à de là
découle ma réponse est ce que la
vaccination doit être obligatoire pour
les soignants absolument je suis
entièrement d'accord avec madame arusha
dessus c'est très bien de se poser des
questions j'ai dirigé un service
clinique pendant des années j'ai vu ce
qui s'est passé dans certaines
vaccinations qui n'était pas obligatoire
et oui effectivement la vaccination doit
être obligatoire parce qu'on traite des
gens parce qu'on s'occupe des gens parce
que ça fait partie du serment qu on a
passé quand on est un médecin et donc la
vaccination doit être obligatoire chez
les soignants
il n'y a pas de honte à demander une
obligation
[Musique]